[Music]
paul's in minneapolis hey paul how are
you
i'm doing all right how are you doing
better than we deserve how can we help
you sir
um so a couple years ago i got screwed
over pretty bad by a business partner
and i was just trying to figure out the
best path to take to forgive them
what was the essence of the deal that
went bad and tell us about it
we had a construction company and
basically i didn't
pay close enough attention to the
finances
um so a lot of money was spent out of
the business account for personal stuff
how much is a lot
several hundred thousand whoa he bought
himself some nice stuff
wow so he basically embezzled the
partnership
is that what you're saying yeah how'd
you find out pretty much um
our taxes hadn't been done in a couple
years because that was supposed to be
his responsibility
and when i went through and um went
through all the bank statements that's
how i
realized the extent of the chaos and
that obviously ended the partnership
abruptly
yes okay and uh was there a discussion
of restitution at the time
of him paying back what was owed no no
i've actually never brought up the eden
you didn't say you owe me this money
back
no oh why uh it's family
what does it have to do with you getting
your money back
guess i don't know i i just didn't want
to press the issue
you know at that point the damage had
been done um
so what kind of family
it's my sister and brother-in-law so
there's your brother-in-law that did it
yes okay all right so what are you
looking forward to
with uh forgiveness i mean i'm assuming
this affects holidays this affects your
parents this affects everything huh
um yeah it affects mainly holidays um
we don't live near each other anymore so
we don't really see each other okay
what are you hoping to gain by
forgiveness
um i guess mainly the release from my
end
you know the financial part is what it
is you know i've moved on from that
but it's the resentment that creeps up
that
i don't want
there's several things man we could talk
about this for an hour dave
you go ahead and talk no you have at it
i think there's a part of you that feels
had and
you i wish i had a better term and if i
had longer to think through it i would
use a kinder term
but you rolled over on yourself and
there's something about
um forgiveness and there's something
about righteousness and justice
and then there's something about
fairness and
whenever i have walked away from a
situation
especially in the moment that's often
the right thing to do
not ever circling back and having the
conversation sometimes it's hard because
i get disappointed in myself
that i didn't x and y and z and i how
mad are you at paul
yeah i sensed that in you
um very you know i could have stopped it
at any time so
yeah and for not looking over his
shoulder and knowing what the books were
doing and
not being more involved you were you
know you handed it to him to do and
walked off and didn't keep up with it
exactly yeah you're a little pissed at
you i can i can relate i've been there
myself
so the first person that you're gonna
have to forgive is paul
and i in fact i just um
had some great insight this weekend i
think writing paul a letter in that
language
dear paul and writing yourself a letter
saying i forgive you
for the things you quote unquote should
have done you didn't know you trusted me
and you got burned it is what it is
but you got to let yourself off the hook
here and then
um i'm a big believer in forgiveness but
forgiveness is
often if not always for you
so i had a banker when i was going broke
that completely
was a crook and lied and messed me over
big time
right in the middle of me going broke um
and so part of the exercise for me when
i went broke and i finally hit all the
way to the bottom
was i had to forgive myself because i
was the idiot that signed these notes i
was the idiot that built this house of
cards and then when they came falling
down i want to blame everybody else
and so i spent a lot of time and effort
um just letting old dave off the hook
because i always thought of myself as a
pretty smart guy until i wasn't and it
shatters it shatters everything right
and so
and and then the an extreme subset of
that then that was very easy to do once
i did that
was let this jerk banker go who's dead
now by the way right
so you know i mean i don't know why that
matters in this conversation but
you know but showed him right yeah i
showed him outlived him but yeah
but i did not kill him that's right yeah
although i considered it at one point
yeah but the uh like we often have with
bankers but the
you know what i did do is make sure that
anybody having anything to do with this
bank never happened again because i talk
about it all the time
anyway so the uh uh but the point being
that
that once i got rid of
me off the list letting him go was easy
right
and that can be writing them a letter
their family that can be just saying i'm
done with it i'm putting it down
having a small scale i don't think you
have any conversation with a guy about
it i think he's inside your heart
yeah i never called that guy and said
anything to him i just let him go in my
mind
set it down